this morning time magazine is launching
first that's a new project that
highlights the achievements of 46
groundbreaking women it includes
exclusive video interviews and features
12 magazine covers each one profiles a
different woman who became the first
female to break the glass ceiling in her
field some of the women shared what
breaking that barrier meant to them
the glass ceiling that vocabulary is
violent right it denotes pressure it
denotes struggle not one thing ever does
it
it's
a series of consistent things
conflict is a sign of possibility many
people see it as
something to be avoided but we can't
grow we can't change without conflict
time editor-in-chief nancy gibbs and
time director of photography and visual
enterprise cara pock join us at the
table good morning to both of you great
to have you guys back here so this is
different than like the time 100. why
did you want to specifically focus on
women and firsts this is this is not a
ranking this is not a power list we just
wanted to tell stories and we wanted to
tell stories that were actually as
different as possible for each other
it's the old notion if you can't see it
you can't be it
and so we felt like we've been having
these conversations about why women are
not breaking through to the to the
c-suite to the top level whether it's
women in hollywood or in tech or in
politics and and so we thought let's
just go out to a bunch of women who have
actually broken through and hear their
stories what motivated them what held
them back what was you know the
life-changing game-changing is there a
common denominator here is there that's
what's great there isn't and in a way
that's the whole point there there is no
one way of thinking about or approaching
this and we actually wanted as much
variety as possible so that you did that
nancy i mean also cure the number 46 is
so random i think you've got the fun the
power the unexpected selena gomez first
person to reach 100 million followers on
instagram why 46 46 it could keep going
yeah it was just an organic list that we
continue to evolve and continue to put
together and we can keep going with it
there are so many great stories to be
told
i love that oprah winfrey and ava
duvernay both made the list and of
course they've now become very good
friends but they are not part of the
unexpected i don't think no i think
though you know if if you are a
scientist then you know elizabeth
blackburn one of the eight female nobel
laureates in the sciences if you're if
you're an oceanographer you know sylvia
earle if you're a tennis player or
anyone else you know serena williams
some of them are much more well-known
than others but but everyone should find
someone with whom they can identify the
the introverts and the extroverts and
the really outgoing pioneers and the
much more private personal people whose
paths were much quieter i love money
davis yes
she's the youngest fantastic sixteen yep
young and when she was 13 she
pitched a shutout at the little league
world series and you know when we
interviewed her she's we asked her what
do you think about the glass ceiling and
she said what's the glass ceiling yes
and it's it's so interesting because her
generation you know that's just not even
in their vocabulary another first even
the photo shoot is different you said
all those photo shoots were done with an
iphone which i think is also a very
interesting take also a first also
there's twelve different covers the
first time we've done two so why the
iphone what were you trying to do a
casual actually it was the photographer
louisa door who i actually discovered on
instagram she's brazilian
and she's an incredible photographer and
uses her iphone as her camera so we saw
her work first realized that she
photographs with her iphone and then she
went around the country and photographed
all of these women who are used to you
know major shoots
reproductions and you know there's
something so
kind of down to earth about this
photographer and subject are we all
fascinated by list nancy so whether it's
david letterman's old top 10 list or
whether it's fortune 500 list
something about it it's a way to
organize our thinking it's a way to look
for patterns and and and prophecies and
understanding i think there's there's
it's an it's a way a very arbitrary
subjective exercise but i also think
there's there's a real value to it and
in this case you know our goal was for
there to be someone that everyone can
see and think i could be that if not
that then that than that you know 46 it
could be 146 it could be you know 10
000. there you've all of this of course
on time but you have a hashtag too right
do you hope that it that it becomes
viral in some way yeah the hashtag is
she is the first and we've put that out
there because that's really where the
conversation is happening on social
media and people have really submitted
great stories of my mother was the first
woman in our family to go to college you
know firsts are is a very broad term and
so a lot of people really have stories
to tell well i love that you're
celebrating intellect success sports
athletics and women all together it's a
great great collection congratulations
thank you another broad definition by
time magazine again i like it you guys
are killing it on the cover thank you